Racial disparities have been a future of the death penalty throughout the
history of the United States.
Of course,
the death penalty was,
uh,
used so much in the south during the time of slavery.
Uh,
and also after the civil war,
during the time of Jim Crow,
justice lynchings and racial oppression,
uh,
and today still a,
there are racial disparities in the infliction of the death penalty.
Uh,
Warren McClusky,
who was sentenced to death in Georgia,
challenged racial disparities in the infliction of the death pony in Georgia in
a case McCleskey vs Kemp.
That's what we're going to start off talking about today.
Uh,
just to sort of set the stage.
And Georgia,
27% of the population is African American.
Look at this.
65% of the victims of murder are African American.
Yet 80% of the people on death row,
uh,
are there for the murders of white people.
Uh,
clearly Georgia punishes the murder of a white person much more severely than it
does the murder of a black person.
Uh,
regardless of who commits a crime,
whether the person is black or white,
uh,
murders of African Americans.
Uh,
are not treated,
uh,
with the same degree of seriousness by the courts.
Uh,
Georgia prosecutors seek the death pony and 70% of the cases where the person,
the defendant is black and the victim is white.
Uh,
32% of white defendants on white victims,
uh,
19% white defendants and black victims and then 15% where it's black on black.
Uh,
so you can see,
uh,
the top two here,
the wide victim has a very prominent role in keeping this number above 20%,
uh,
as well as the race of the defendant.
Uh,
in terms of the imposition of the death pony,
22% black defendant,
white victim cases,
uh,
are,
the death penalty is imposed on those cases,
only 8%,
where it's a white defendant and a white victim and then three and 1% for the
other racial combinations.
The ball to study was actually two studies,
uh,
often referred to as the ball,
the studies if it was just one,
but there were two,
the procedural reforms study,
uh,
and then the charging and sentencing study.
And the second the charging and sentencing one is the one that's really
important.
Uh,
one of the criticisms that have been made of,
uh,
studies of the death penalty and of racial disparities with,
they were all these variables that weren't taken into account that if you just
said,
uh,
of all the people that were sentenced to death in the commission of a robbery,
the number of blacks was much greater than the number of whites.
People would say yes,
but there are a lot of other factors that have to be considered.
And what this study tried to do was take those factors into account.
A total of 230 variables,
uh,
were taken into account.
This is probably the most sophisticated,
uh,
study of sentencing,
that has ever been done about 2,500 Georgia cases.
This was from when the death,
plenty was re-instituted in Georgia until the time,
uh,
that the study was done.
And,
uh,
they found about 1600 people were eligible for the death penalty.
Uh,
but only 128 actually were sentenced to death.
So you see the tremendous difference,
uh,
in the number of people who could have received the death penalty,
but only 8% of the people did.
So the question was what were the factors that influenced how this narrowing
took place from going to 1600 a to 128 and to what extent,
if any,
did race play a role in that?
Um,
warm McCluskey was prosecuted in Fulton County.
That's Atlanta,
Georgia and of the 17 was charged for killing a police officer,
warm a Tuskegee was African American.
Uh,
the police officer was white.
of the 17 people arrested for murder of a police officer,
uh,
during between 1973 and 79,
which is when this study was conducted,
a only McCluskey was sentenced to death.
Um,
the US and his colleagues who did this study,
uh,
performed a rigorous multiple regression analysis to try to take all these 230
variables that they had found and see how they factored into the process of who
got the death pony and who didn't.
To what extent things that were legally relevant may have factored in like
multiple victims or crime against a stranger or torture.
But also to what extent did nonlegal factors like race come into play?
Uh,
and,
uh,
after,
running,
uh,
the multiple regression analysis and looking at different,
aspects of this,
the,
uh,
researchers concluded that a white person,
excuse me,
an African American leg McCluskey who's charged with a murder of a white person,
a is 4.3 times more likely to be sentenced to death.
Uh,
then,
uh,
other racial combinations,
um,
McCluskey race two claims,
a one that there was intentional racial discrimination against him because of
his race.
Uh,
and because the race of the victim and McCluskey his lawyer,
John Charles Boger,
the Naacp Legal Defense Fund,
when he stood up before the court to make the argument for McCluskey,
he said,
if we had a law that said the death plenty could only be imposed in cases where
the victim was white,
it certainly would be unconstitutional.
In fact,
at one time in our history,
the punishment for crimes did very,
uh,
based on the race of the victim as well as the race of the defendant.
Uh,
but of course today that would not be in at the time I'm a classic use case,
uh,
that would not be a permissible basis for distinguishing which case has got the
death penalty in which did not.
Uh,
so his argument was race discrimination,
intentional race discrimination came into play.
And then he made a second argument based on the cruel and unusual punishment
clause of the eighth amendment,
uh,
in which he said there was an impermissible risk,
not necessarily intentional,
but that there were so many discretionary decisions being made.
So many people had so much discretion that by the time,
uh,
the death pony was or was not imposed,
there was too great a risk of the death Poli,
uh,
of race in influencing who received the death pony.
This was what Justice Douglas had found in Furman versus Georgia.
And that was the reason for his vote to strike down the death.
Polian Furman versus Georgia was that there was so much room for discretion to
come into the process,
uh,
that it did not eliminate the risk or it didn't minimize the risk of race and
poverty,
uh,
coming into play.
Uh,
with regard to the first claim,
the equal protection claim,
uh,
the court set a very high standard of proof that warm McCluskey had to prove
that the decision makers in his case a acted with discriminatory purpose,
uh,
that unlike a jury challenges the jury pools where you look at the number of
people in the population and say it's 50% African American and you look at the
jury pool and it's 30%.
And you infer from that,
uh,
that there's discrimination or employment cases,
the decision to impose the death plenty.
It's made one jury at a time and each jury is an ad hoc body that comes together
and makes that decision one time.
Uh,
really the decision making,
uh,
that results in these disparities is decision making,
by prosecutors.
The two most important decisions in every death penalty case is one,
does the prosecutors seek the death penalty to begin with?
Most of the time they don't.
Many prosecutors never seek the death.
Polly,
some other prosecutors seek at every opportunity.
So there's wide variation in each prosecutors elected and most states from a
different judicial district.
So the practices in one district can be completely different than the practices.
And another,
the second critical decision is whether a plea bargain the case and resolve it
with a sentence other than death in exchange for the defendant pleading guilty
and waving a trial.
And that's where the overwhelming majority of capital cases are resolved.
And they're resolved,
obviously without the death,
plenty being imposed because he,
the prosecutor didn't seek it or because the prosecutor offers a plea bargain
and the cases resolved with a plea bargain.
But what about the times from the prosecutor won't offer a plea bargain and the
cases are taken to trial.
A Supreme Court,
uh,
as it had done in other cases of selective prosecution,
sets a very high standard,
uh,
for trying to challenge,
the decisions being made by prosecutors,
uh,
that exceptionally clear proof because of the value of discretion which can work
in the defendant's favor if the prosecution prosecutor is merciful or can work
adversely if the prosecutor decides just to seek the death pony,
uh,
exceptionally clear proof and we don't know how clear it has to be because
nobody has made this standard yet,
uh,
has proven this yet exceptionally clear proof is required to infer that there's
been race discrimination.
In other words,
the person challenging the decision has to be able to show that the decision was
because of race and not merely in spite of it.
And the court,
uh,
has done this in other cases before McCluskey his case and uh,
weight versus United States,
a number of people who had burned their draft card,
we're charged with evading the draft.
Uh,
when they prosecuted,
they said,
well,
wait a minute.
There were 600,000 people,
uh,
who didn't register for the draft and we're the only ones who got prosecuted.
And it was probably because we burned our draft cards.
And so we're being discriminated against because we exercised our first
amendment right to protest,
supreme court rejected and said,
you have to show that because of your exercise,
not million spite of,
uh,
that the prosecutors singled you out.
It's pretty obvious that the prosecutors had a,
but basically what that decision has done in subsequent decisions is pretty much
insulate from any judicial review decisions made by prosecutors in terms of
whether to seek the death penalty and whether to resolve cases with plea
bargains.
We'll also see that it's difficult for defendants to make that challenge because
often the information that is needed is just simply not available.
Uh,
with regard the Eighth Amendment Challenge,
uh,
the question was,
is there some risk of race playing a role?
Uh,
there are risks that other kinds of prejudice will influence criminal trials.
But the question about race is,
at what point does the risks become constitutionally inacceptable?
Uh,
unacceptable.
So those were the questions that were before the court to look at both of these.
Let's first look at what the court said about this statistics.
Uh,
Justice Powell road for the majority,
the five justices,
this was a five to four decision justice Powell writing,
uh,
for the majority,
says at most,
the ball to study indicates a discrepancy that appears to correlate with race
and then goes on to say disparities in sentencing are inevitable,
which is one of the most striking lines in the McClusky opinion.
I guess the court in Brown versus board of education could have said differences
in the kind of education children receive at school are inevitable.
Uh,
so we'll allow separate but equal to go on.
the court didn't do that in the Brown case,
but it did do it.
And the mccloskey case,
uh,
basically,
saying that we are not going to assume that one is unexplained,
that these disparities that we see,
uh,
because discretion is so important to our criminal justice system that
prosecutors have discretion that juries have discretion,
uh,
that because that's so important.
We're not going to assume that what is unexplained is invidious.
Uh,
basically all the evidence is pointing to one reason for this and the baldest
study certainly isolated,
uh,
reasons for this.
But the court said,
we're not going to assume that race was the factor that caused Warren McCluskey
to be sentenced to death or that influenced the decision.
Doesn't have to be the only reason,
but,
uh,
that Warren McCluskey got the death penalty.
Um,
the court also said in light of the safeguards that the court had adopted a to
minimize racial bias,
uh,
the value of the jury trial and the benefits of discretion.
Again,
back to the benefits of discretion.
Uh,
the court holds that the ball of study does not demonstrate a constitutionally
significant risk of racial bias is the risk of racial bias.
It's pretty well established by the study.
Uh,
but the court concludes that it's not constitutionally significant in terms of
affecting the capital sentencing process.
Uh,
in Georgia.
the court also says it's nondiscriminatory or disproportionate,
disproportionate when applied to Warren McCluskey because McCluskey committed a
crime for which the death pony could be imposed.
Of course,
if,
if there's no problem,
anytime a person that sends to death for a crime for which the death penalty can
be imposed,
then you stop right there.
And that's the end of the inquiry.
But as we saw earlier,
uh,
out of 1600 people who are Algebra for the death and the only 128 received it,
so a lot of decisions and discretion is being exercised to get down to the
people like Warren McClusky who ended up in that 128 who were sentenced to death
and not in the hundreds of other people who were not,
uh,
sentenced to death.
Uh,
Justice Powell also says that,
uh,
the sentence in this case was consistent with the procedures that Georgia has
for imposing the death penalty.
These were upheld by the court and Greg versus Georgia in 1976.
One of the,
uh,
arguments McCluskey and made is that everybody in short,
you're discriminated.
The legislature,
the governor,
the juries,
the prosecutors,
everyone in court said you can't say the legislature a discriminated because we
upheld the Georgia statute in 1976.
Of course that was upholding the statute as written,
but not as applied.
Uh,
and mccloskey,
his challenge was,
now that we've seen this statute and operation for some period of time,
what we're seeing are these rather dramatic racial disparities,
4.3 times more likely to get the death penalty if you're a black man like Warren
McCluskey and the victim is as a white person.
Uh,
but,
uh,
the court says because he could have received the death pony because this is
under the statute which allows the death penalty if there's a homicide and
aggravating circumstances.
Uh,
we're not going to assume that the death penalty was wantonly and freakishly
imposed.
Uh,
in this case,
uh,
two other considerations.
The court mentions one that if McCluskey is a case was taken to its logical
conclusion,
it would throw into question,
uh,
the entire criminal justice system,
that if we looked at race bias,
uh,
in the imposition of the death pony,
we could be soon confronted with claims that there's race discrimination in
other kinds of sentencing.
And there certainly is,
we know that there's race discrimination and penalties for drug use,
for example.
Uh,
and basically the court is saying if we start looking at race and depth pony
cases,
uh,
then we might have to start looking at race in all kinds of other criminal cases
where it appears that the sentencings are more severe as applied to African
Americans or Hispanics or whoever,
uh,
that applied to whites.
Uh,
Justice Brennan call this,
uh,
the fear of too much justice.
Uh,
and others could argue that if there are those racial disparities,
uh,
which there are,
throughout the criminal justice system,
what the courts ought to be about is dealing with them,
uh,
not sweeping them under the rug by having a standard of proof that no one can
meet.
But that's what the court did.
Uh,
in this case,
uh,
justice probably even goes on to say hard to understand this,
that it could even be applied to other characteristics such as gender.
Of course.
Normally we don't allow discrimination on the basis of gender,
but he goes even further than that to say that that if McCluskey his claim is we
might even apply to facial characteristics or physical attractiveness.
Now,
justice Lewis Powell lived in Richmond for genuine,
which was the capital of confederacy at one time.
He surely knew that African Americans had been subject to discrimination
throughout the history of this country and we're still subject to
discrimination.
It was in no way comparable to people based on their facial characteristics are
based upon their physical attractiveness.
So it's an,
it's a,
it's a striking line,
uh,
in the opinion,
that,
that he would say that a claim based on race is as trivial as a claim based on
physical attractiveness or,
or facial features.
Uh,
he says there's one other factor and that's,
that this is best presented to the legislature's,
uh,
that they can weigh the studies and the information.
And they can decide what's appropriate.
Of course,
the problem is that,
uh,
legislatures are very driven by the majority.
Uh,
and if someone's constitutional rights are being violated,
the buck really stops with the courts.
Uh,
it's the courts,
uh,
that would have to step in and do something about,
or race discrimination.
It's unlikely that particularly when you have states like Texas and Georgia and
Alabama and others where the death pony is immensely popular,
uh,
that those states are going to look at the death pony and decide that they're
not going to impose it.
Although,
as we will see,
one state North Carolina did pass a law to look at race disparities and the
influence of race,
uh,
in capital sentencing.
Uh,
and what they saw was,
uh,
not a very favorable with regard to the fair implement a fair infliction of the
death.
Plenty of North Carolina Justice Brennan in his descent in this case says at
some point where McCluskey undoubtedly ask his lawyer what the chances were that
he was going to get the death penalty.
He says,
an answer to that question would have to be disturbing,
uh,
because the lawyer would have to tell McCluskey that nothing about the fact of
his crimes.
Uh,
nothing about his own personal background.
His prior record would be as influential in terms of whether he received the
Death Poli,
uh,
as his race,
and the race of his victim.
It's a remarkable thing that William Brennan in his lofty perch and the supreme
court or the United States could so clearly understand conversations that
lawyers and people facing the death penalty have in jails all over the United
States.
Uh,
he said those conversations which continued until this day would be the most
eloquent desense to the McClusky opinion of all.
The question then is,
is there a remedy after McCluskey for race discrimination,
one of the first cases to present this was another Georgia case of a felony and
wildly Dobbs who was sentenced to death and Walker county.
Uh,
Georgia here was a case where powerful evidence that everybody involved in the
case,
the jurors,
the prosecutor,
the defense lawyer,
the judge,
uh,
that there were these racial attitudes of the community.
Had this history of race,
uh,
and yet,
Dobbs lost,
uh,
the court ruled against him.
He said on the first prong that he hadn't proven intentional racial
discrimination.
And we've talked about why and McCluskey why that is almost impossible.
It is impossible to prove after the McClusky case.
And then the court said with regard to the risk of race playing apart and Dobbs
case,
uh,
that,
as long as these procedures existed,
such as,
uh,
procedures prohibiting discrimination in the composition of the jury pools,
a Batson versus Kentucky,
which says that a prosecutor's theoretically can't strike on the basis of race,
uh,
that,
other things that the Supreme Court,
uh,
had had held and the Georgia death penalty statute and the aggravating and
mitigating circumstances.
And the way,
uh,
it decided,
or guided how the death point it was to be imposed.
It said,
because these procedures,
Georgia had minimize the risk.
Now this is an important point.
Notice it didn't say the procedures had to work.
It only looks at whether there are procedures that minimize the risk.
And if there are such procedures,
stop right there.
And that's what the court did in Dobbs.
This case,
what it really says is that as long as these procedures exist and they don't
have to be implemented in the case,
it doesn't have to be invoked.
Uh,
in the case,
uh,
the court is going to reject a claim of race discrimination today,
virtually impossible for a defendant to get even a hearing on a claim of race
discrimination.
Even though everybody knows that race is playing a role,
very often a dominant role.
On the question of do we seek the death pony or do we not?
We know that the prominence and the race of the victim is a critical factor.
Uh,
we know that the race of the defendant,
uh,
is a factor,
particularly interracial crimes,
particularly if there's sexual assault or behavior like that involved.
Uh,
and there's some politics involved as well too.
Those are all extra legal factors that shouldn't be considered.
Uh,
but they're very much central to the decision to seek death,
uh,
in many cases.
Let's talk for a moment about,
uh,
Dominic green's case in,
in Texas where he did at least get an issue of race discrimination before the
Texas Court of criminal appeals.
Uh,
this case involved a crime committed by four people,
three blacks and one white.
Two of the blacks who participated in a crime may plea bargains and got out with
prison sentences.
The White Fella,
he didn't get charged at all,
so he walked away free from this crime.
Uh,
green was sentenced to death,
uh,
and the prison people,
the jail people intercepted some letters that he wrote to one of the other
fellows who was accused in the case,
uh,
repeatedly using the word sort of the wrap word Nigga in Igg,
Aa a and he signed off the letter as a trigger happy Nigga.
And,
uh,
that was presented to the jury case.
Went up on the argument that this was not necessary,
uh,
to put this letter in a,
but the Texas court held that the probative value outweighs any prejudicial
effect and that it was properly admitted,
uh,
at Greens trial and,
and green was put to death.
Um,
let's look at John Bass,
this case.
This was the case.
Uh,
that points out the problem of getting information.
United States government has been prosecuting capital cases since 1988 and we
know that the federal government prosecuted Steph pony cases more than twice as
often against African Americans than against whites.
Really quite remarkable.
And the federal death row is quite remarkable and it's overwhelmingly people of
color.
Uh,
also the Justice Department plea bargains more often with whites and other words
in that second decision that prosecutors make,
we know that federal prosecutors are more likely to offer a life sentence and
allow a person to escape the death pony if they're white than if they're black.
All this information is presented to the United States district court,
which says,
well,
we need to look into this.
Uh,
we need to require the prosecution to provide some information about its
charging practices so that we can see if there's some explanation for why it is
that more blacks are charged,
uh,
that blacks are denied plea bargains.
Uh,
that's upheld by the United States Court of Appeals for the sixth circuit.
but the United States Supreme Court Grants Hersha Rari and summarily reverses
the case,
uh,
and basically says that bass has not made a credible showing up discrimination,
that the raw statistics,
which the only statistics he can have because he doesn't have the information
that the court had ordered me this closed.
Uh,
but it says all this is,
is raw statistics.
It shows they're seeing the death putting more often against blacks.
It shows that they're giving plea offers more often a whites,
but that alone doesn't really tell you anything because in theory,
there could be some other explanations for that.
Uh,
besides race.
another case involving information,
uh,
was,
in Ray United States,
uh,
this was a fellow named Williams who was one of 14 people who was indicted for a
terrible crime.
Uh,
they were smuggling people into the United States and the back of a truck.
and as a result of the heat and the failure to adequately take care of these
folk,
19 people,
uh,
suffocated,
died,
uh,
in this truck.
Uh,
and there were 14 people indicted for this,
uh,
by the only stuff that,
that point against one.
And that was Williams.
And so Williams of course raised this with the court.
Why,
why me?
Why am I the one for which the government seeing the death pony when the 13
other people who were involved in the smuggling operation just as I was,
and not saying he shouldn't be punished for what he did,
but why is the,
why is the death penalty being sought?
In his case,
a judge Gilmore,
the United States district judge,
this was a federal prosecution in federal court in Texas.
The district judge said that she wanted the Department of Justice to give
information about its sentencing practices,
uh,
to the defense so they can make an assessment of why it was that Williams was
charged and not other people.
And Williams also pointed to these larger racial disparities in the use of the
federal death public.
Um,
and then when the government wouldn't turn the information over,
a judge Komora said,
well,
I'm going to instruct the jury that I asked for this information and the
government refused to give it.
This is sort of like a missing witness instruction.
Sometimes if one side has the ability to call a certain witness and doesn't call
that witness,
uh,
the court will give an instruction to the jury,
can draw some inference from the figure to present the witness.
A mandamus relief is very unusual,
uh,
and only for a,
an abuse of discretion and almost never granted against district judges.
But here,
the United States Court of Appeals for the fifth circuit issued a regimen,
Damon saying that a judge can more,
could not give that instruction,
uh,
and said that she had abused her discretion,
and therefore prohibited as it turned out that case,
all of them when we did go to trial Williamson's not sentenced to death.
Uh,
but here again,
we see the courts just simply unwilling to give up any information that might
explain the racial disparities.
Uh,
the case that sort of is the genesis of all of those.
The case called in re Armstrong versus United States,
uh,
which had to do with the disparities and drug sentencing with crack cocaine and
powdered cocaine.
Uh,
once again,
a district court did order disclosure,
it had up to a court of appeals,
but the Supreme Court of the United States said,
no,
you couldn't get the information.
Of course,
if you can't get the information,
you can't prove your case.
So the court has done two things with regard to race claims and race cases.
One is set a very high standard,
uh,
that,
exceptionally clear proof that the defendant has to show because of,
and not merely in spite of,
uh,
and,
and secondly,
uh,
deny the evidence in,
in these cases,
the court has said,
we're not going to look into the reasons for the prosecutors,
uh,
decisions.
We're not going to require the prosecutor to give up information that might help
us understand why certain decisions were made.
Uh,
the result is,
uh,
basically that,
even though race plays such an important role,
uh,
in who sends to death,
which cases advanced a death penalty or are seen as stuff point of cases,
advanced a penalty phase and does imposed,
uh,
the courts almost never now based on McCluskey,
look into why it was a and what prosecutorial decisions were made,
uh,
and whether race influenced those decisions at all.
The last case,
state versus a Dorsey,
uh,
this is the monument,
out in front of the courthouse in Shreveport,
Louisiana,
and it's Keto parish,
uh,
where we have Robert E.
Lee and Stonewall Jackson and Jefferson Davis.
And then we have sort of the all,
uh,
every man sort of soldier for the confederacy,
as well as the confederate flag.
Uh,
one of the jurors,
one of the African American jurors who pass by that going in the courthouse
said,
you know,
I don't feel very comfortable,
uh,
coming into a courthouse that has this huge,
and you can see this is this,
and not just a little little plaque or something.
This is a huge monument,
concrete monument maintained there in front of the courthouse,
right where you come.
And he says,
I,
I don't think that's right.
Uh,
these people were in rebellion against the United States of America and they
were in rebellion because of race.
Uh,
and so he was excused from jury duty.
Dorsey's lawyers raised the question that race came into play in his case
because of course,
all the jurors,
black or white had to go pass this a symbol of the confederacy.
Uh,
but the Louisiana Supreme Court,
uh,
held,
that,
uh,
that did not in any way interfere with this trial and affirm just a sentence.
There has been legislation passed and just a few states,
uh,
to deal with race discrimination since the courts are not dealing with it.
Kentucky,
uh,
Pastor Racial Justice Act,
North Carolina passed a racial Justice Act and actually,
uh,
had hearings on it.
Uh,
two hearings,
one involving a,
one person sends to death.
And the second hearing involving three other people sentenced to death,
uh,
and Cumberland County,
North Carolina.
And the findings made a,
as will be discussed with Henderson Hill and another segment,
uh,
were really,
quite striking.
Uh,
it's one thing to look at the jury strikes within a particular case and see that
there's the dis disparate number,
uh,
used against black,
as opposed to white perspective jurors.
But what happened,
uh,
in the racial justice act cases in North Carolina was they put together all of
the jury strikes in death penalty cases in North Carolina.
And when you aggregate all those numbers and you see that over the course of the
time,
since North Carolina has had the death penalty,
a white person is,
or excuse me,
a black person is twice as likely to be struck,
uh,
from jury duty.
When the prosecutor has a chance to strike a black person,
it's twice as often that they're going to strike a black person as a white
person.
Uh,
the court also found that the race neutral reasons,
prosecutors we're giving,
uh,
we're often,
not only pre textual,
uh,
but it came out in the hearing,
that the prosecutors had a cheat sheet,
a and they had the race neutral reasons already written out,
uh,
before they ever,
saw the jurors.
So when a prosecutor struck a black juror and under Batson versus Kentucky,
the judge,
if it was challenged,
the judge would say,
what was your reason?
You just look down and say,
ah,
that person looked distant or solen or some other,
uh,
race neutral reason that had been supplied before you ever saw the juror.
And the way the jury behaved,
uh,
judge weeks,
found that,
uh,
prosecutors in North Carolina instead of,
trying to study how to present their cases to diverse juries and how to have a
fair system had instead tried to figure out how do we resist the Batson versus
Kentucky decision.
How do we continue to exclude black people from serving?
In both cases,
he found that race had been a factor,
which was the statutory language race had been a factor,
uh,
in the imposition of the death poem.
And under the statute,
uh,
the four cases,
the sentences in the four cases were reduced from death to life in prison.
Uh,
what did the North Carolina legislature do upon finding that race had played
such a dramatic role in death penalty cases?
Uh,
it repealed the racial justice act.
and so now,
uh,
people in North Carolina who had the opportunity to make claims that McCluskey
basically bart everywhere else,
but in North Carolina and allowed by statute,
uh,
can no longer make those claims.
Finally,
in federal cases,
uh,
federal jurors are required to sign a statement and are instructed that they are
not to let the race of the victim or the race of the defendant come into play
when they make the decision.
Uh,
whether or not this is very effective in presenting race from coming into play,
uh,
is subject to debate.
Uh,
but overall,
as we look back on what we've talked about in this segment,
we see that the reluctance of courts to deal with race,
certainly in North Carolina,
we see the reluctance to deal when race is proven to repeal the law.
So that can't be proven anymore.
Uh,
and North Carolina was the only in Kentucky,
the only states that have passed racial justice acts.
So claims of race discrimination,
uh,
are seldom,
if ever going to be heard,
uh,
in the courts despite the fact that race is such a prominent feature of the
death penalty always has been and still is today.